[Music]
over 67 of companies have experienced a
cyber attack and it is expected that by
the security market will be worth 170.4
billion dollars
with six-figure salaries being the norm
for a variety of security roles
it is projected that more than 4 million
cyber security job openings will be
unfilled in 2021
underscoring how much companies are in
need of knowledgeable security
professionals
who can protect their core operations
and enable innovation
to answer that demand udacity has teamed
up with
cutting-edge security experts to teach
you how to find
exploit and thus determine the risk of
vulnerabilities
with the ethical hacker nanodegree
program
as an ethical hacker you will use your
unique skill set to evaluate risks while
protecting a company's most valuable
system
with the guidance of udacity's expert
instructors
you'll learn how to investigate and
research vulnerabilities
identify common security risks and
produce
meaningful reports you will have the
opportunity to test your skills into
real world projects that cover
deconstructing a security system
hacking applications phishing and social
engineering attacks
and even obfuscating back door
connections
you're in for an exhilarating ride and
there's never been a better time to get
on
expand your cybersecurity career and
enroll in the ethical hacker nana degree
program
today